-The President openly celebrated
violence against a reporter
as Saudi Arabia lied about
the death of a journalist.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tonight, President Trump
traveled to Texas
to campaign for his former
nemesis, Senator Ted Cruz.
Trump, of course,
famously called him Lying Ted
during the 2016 campaign,
but on his way to Texas,
he was asked by reporters
if he still felt that way,
and he gave Cruz a new nickname.
-Is he no longer Lying Ted?
-To me,
he's not Lying Ted anymore.
-What is he now?
-He's Beautiful Ted.
-No. No, you can call Ted Cruz
a lot of things,
but "beautiful"
is not one of them.
[ Laughter ]
Ted Cruz once took a picture
with a butter cow,
and the only thing
that looked like it was melting
was Ted Cruz.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is pulling out
all the stops for the midterms
to try to avoid
the impending blue wave,
and the reason these midterms
feel so tense is that right now,
millions of Americans feel
their democracy isn't working.
Republicans are illegally
purging voters
and gerrymandering districts.
Four Justices
on the Supreme Court
have now been appointed
by two presidents
who lost the popular vote.
And the most recent nominee was
confirmed by a Senate majority
that actually represents
fewer Americans
than in the Senate minority.
What we now have
is a system that does
the opposite
of what the people want.
It's like if Lays
let everybody vote
on a new potato-chip flavor,
and a month later,
they announced that the winner
was fried liver and cilantro.
[ Laughter ]
You'd be like,
"I think something
might be wrong
with the voting system."
[ Laughter ]
People are angry
that a minority faction
is ruling the country and
ignoring what most people want,
and they've expressed that anger
in various ways,
like confronting politicians
in public
or protesting in the Capitol.
And Republicans
have responded to that fury
by calling their own
constituents paid protestors
and claiming the left
is practicing mob violence.
-When you have nothing to run on
over the last two years,
then you turn to something
that is popular
among the liberal mob
on the left, right? Violence.
-We will not be bullied by
the screams of paid protesters
and name-calling by the mob.
-The far left mob
is not letting up.
-You don't hand matches
to an arsonist.
And you don't give power
to an angry, left-wing mob,
and that's what they've become.
The choice
could not be more clear.
Democrats produce mobs.
Republicans produce jobs.
-First of all, when Trump finds
a rhyme like "mobs" and "jobs,"
that's his Gettysburg Address.
[ Laughter and applause ]
'Cause that's really...
And you know he was up all night
trying to crack that one.
"Democrats produce mobs.
Republicans
produce fob-- fobs?
Bobs, knobs --
Oh! Oh! Jobs!"
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Second, you're accusing
Democrats of acting like a mob?
Because I can only remember
one mob in recent history,
and I'm positive
they weren't Democrats.
Democrats only use tiki torches
to keep mosquitos away
from their vegan barbecues.
[ Laughter ]
You guys are the ones
who run the government
like a protection racket.
Republicans all look like
they should be
cracking their knuckles
in a butcher shop,
telling the owner,
"Nice place you got here.
Would be a shame
if something happened to it."
[ Laughter ]
If you took any photo
of Trump's aides
and added Clemenza
from "The Godfather,"
no one would notice.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They'd notice the hat.
And then, on Friday,
Trump posted yet another
one of his weird
Rose Garden Twitter videos
where he again claimed Democrats
were an angry mob.
-The Democrats don't like
being called an angry mob,
but, really,
that's what they've become.
They've gone so far left,
they can't even believe
that they're over there.
They don't know that's going on.
They're losing it,
and they shouldn't be.
-They're losing it?
[ Laughter ]
You look like you just wandered
out of those bushes
and made a stranger
point a camera at you.
It looks like a Bigfoot video
where Bigfoot decided
to try his hand
at public speaking.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Me Bigfoot.
Bigfoot friend.
Bigfoot...friend.
Don't chase Bigfoot."
So, Republicans
are accusing the left
of acting like a violent mob.
Meanwhile, there are Republicans
who are literally violent,
like Montana Congressman
Greg Gianforte,
who pled guilty to physically
assaulting a reporter last year
when that reporter
tried to ask Gianforte
a question about healthcare.
And in case you forgot what that
sounded like, here's the audio.
-You've been waiting to make
your decision about healthcare
until you saw the bill,
and it just came out.
-We'll talk to you
about that later.
-Yeah, but there's
not gonna be time.
-Okay.
Speak with Shane, please.
[ Rustling, crashing ]
I'm sick and tired of you guys!
The last guy that came in here,
you did the same thing!
Get the hell out of here!
-Man, it is amazing how often
Republicans get caught
doing [bleep] things on tape.
I mean, a Congressman was taped
body-slamming a reporter.
Trump was taped discussing
a payment to cover up an affair.
And Steven Miller was taped
eating his lunch
in the White House basement.
-Okay, Steven,
time for your feeding.
-[ Shrieking ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-So, last week Trump,
the law-and-order president,
went to Montana to campaign for
violent criminal Greg Gianforte,
and he made it clear
that he is totally against
political violence of any kind,
unless it's
a sick wrestling move,
in which case,
he thinks it's awesome.
-Greg is smart.
And by the way,
never wrestle him.
You understand that?
Never.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Any guy that can do a body slam,
he's my kind of --
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's my guy.
-So Trump says a congressman
who body-slammed a reporter
is his kind of guy.
And let's not forget,
Trump also told his supporters
to knock the crap
out of protesters
and promised to pay
their legal fees if they did.
He's an actual crime boss.
I mean, look at him.
He sweats like
he's being dangled
off the side of a roof
by Batman.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Trump is the classic
fake tough guy from Queens.
If he weren't president, he'd be
the guy sitting on a park bench
in Flushing Meadows, saying,
"Who you looking at?"
to the squirrels.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But Trump's praise for Gianforte
is especially gross
after the murder
of "Washington Post" columnist
and U.S. resident
Jamal Khashoggi,
who disappeared after walking
into the Saudi consulate
in Istanbul three weeks ago.
And yet, on Friday,
after a series of lies
and a sham investigation,
the Saudis released
a truly absurd account
of Khashoggi's death.
-Saudi Arabia
now publicly confirming
that the Saudi journalist
and "Washington Post"
contributor Jamal Khashoggi
is dead
in the middle of the night.
Announced by officials
in Riyadh,
said he died as a result
of a physical altercation
inside the Saudi consulate.
-State prosecutors
say the Saudi writer,
last seen walking into the
consulate to get papers
for his upcoming wedding,
got into a fistfight
inside that led to his death.
-That's insane.
They're claiming
he got into a fistfight
while he was trying to get
paperwork for his wedding.
The only time anyone has gotten
into a fistfight over a wedding
is on MTV's "True Life"
I'm Getting Married."
-Do you have any [bleep] clue
who you're talking to right now?
Besides the fact
that it's my [bleep] wedding,
I'll [bleep]
cut you the [bleep] up!
I will gut you like the [bleep]
piece of [bleep] that you are!
Do you understand?!
Don't you [bleep] dare
come up to me like that
on my [bleep] wedding!
'Cause I'll hunt you down
like [bleep] cattle,
and I'll gut you!
[ Laughter, audience "Oohs" ]
-Our show will never
be as good as that show.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, I'd love to see him
renting that tuxedo.
"I need a lot of room in my arms
for angry walking!"
[ Laughter ]
There's so many reasons
not to believe this obvious lie.
Multiple suspects have direct
links to the Crown Prince.
Even Republicans in Congress,
who are fierce allies of Trump,
have called
this explanation absurd.
No one, and I mean no one,
is dumb enough to believe
the Saudi explanation.
-U.S. President Trump says he
believes the Saudi explanation,
calling it "a good first step."
-That's right. Trump said the
Saudi explanation was credible.
Now, because he won't
release his tax returns,
we don't know exactly what
Trump's personal financial ties
are to Saudi Arabia.
Last week, Trump tweeted,
"I have no financial interest
in Saudi Arabia."
So you can believe Trump
when he says
he has no financial interest
in Saudi Arabia,
or you could take it
from this guy.
-I love the Saudis.
Many are in this building.
Saudi Arabia, and I get along
great with all of them.
They buy apartments from me.
They spend $40 million,
$50 million.
Am I supposed to dislike them?
I like them very much.
-"They give me money,
so I like them,"
is the literal definition
of a bribe.
[ Laughter ]
Trump can be
so disorienting sometimes
because he just spells out in
plain language why he's corrupt.
He's like a guy who robbed
a bank, telling the cops,
"I pointed a gun at the teller,
so he gave me the cash.
What am I supposed to do?
Not take it?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
So while pundits and Republicans
whine about civility,
the president was celebrating
violence against a reporter
and standing by the Saudis.
It's a protection racket.
If you pay them off,
they'll protect you.
There's even a word for that.
It's called...
-The mob.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]